yo what's up y'all this is nina and you
can check me out on a bootleg calf
podcast
welcome to the bootleg kit podcast we
got a special guest in here my guy not
not here man welcome my brother kev
what's good man finally finally you're
here so finally we're here man um you
had a pretty great pandemic uh i feel
like your life changed during the
pandemic a little bit man a little bit
you know just a lot of it yeah i mean it
was it was a you know 2020 was a very
challenging but a very for your career
for for my career yeah your career
went up for sure in a certain
couple more listeners yeah
quite a few more listeners yeah i mean
yeah i feel like you know some people
like uh used uh the last couple of years
to like as really as like an excuse as
to why they're
whatever the [ __ ] down badge i'm not
even talking about just musicians but
just people in general but like a lot of
people really like
use it as quite the opposite yeah yeah
yeah i feel like that was like the year
that everybody needed like
mute like the music within itself and
music was substance exactly because they
were listening at the crib correct or
they were listening in their car they
weren't standing on [ __ ] man couches
there was nothing else to do but to
listen to music exactly ways was all
cleared up
you know nobody was on the road
six flags shut down all the theme parks
are shut down no for sure that's why i
feel like guys like yourself like we saw
a lot of guys have like the best the
zelda guys were already popping but they
really went next level
um freddy and alfredo and uh
even if you look at the grammy
nominations right it was like a bunch of
rap [ __ ] it was like j electronica and d
smoke and exactly freddy gibbs and royce
exactly exactly it was good for music i
think yeah i feel like we got a heavy
outpour of like real rap during that
time just amazing rap 2020 i think was
like probably
up there was one of my favorite years in
hip-hop in recent memory as far as just
like the stuff i like like like just the
music that was released just the quality
was i feel like on another level i would
say so yeah it was up there what part of
la are you from um i'm from the crenshaw
district okay you know um
uh you know near like lemur park like
that around that area crenshawn king
grew up born race over there went to
school over there audubon middle school
dorsey high school so
um talk about like for you because you
know la's such a interesting place when
we think of like the biggest artist to
come out of la like
you got someone like kendrick who
is the biggest but also is like not
gang-affiliated right you know grew up
in the neighborhood but like
you know wasn't a part of that lifestyle
um and then on the other on the flip
side you got snoop dogg who's probably
the most famous rapper of all time but
just got done sea walking and throwing a
[ __ ] at the super bowl
you know i think like there's always a
stereotype about la people
uh when you don't live here
um
that it's like all one thing and it's
but it's such a dynamic place and i
think that like what what you're
bringing to the table is like a very
like
just a dope perspective
on what it's like to not be wrapped up
in that lifestyle but still kind of be
from those areas you know definitely
exactly i think me my my thing has
always been you know um
just giving like a fly on the wall
perspective because i know a lot of guys
from both sides you know and you know
just haven't had watched it like from a
you know like closely you know but not
being directly in it and tied to it you
know just
um
gave me
um
the ability to give a different
perspective coming right right coming
from you know um the crenshaw district
so
you know uh you know i know a lot of
guys are familiar with you know nipsey
ice cubes of course
when they hear south central
so and just the arena that
these guys were in you know gave
the world
i feel like a perspective of what la is
coming from like that area
but i i feel like with me you know it's
it's
it's
being close to it but not being in it
right you know so what do you think is
the biggest misconception about
la in general i think like
living here for five or six years now
i think it's like
from my perspective it's like people
come out here but they don't really ever
come to la they go to like the valley or
they go to hollywood or they go to bed
really the closest part of la they've
been to is when they landed exactly
exactly i think the biggest
misconception is that everybody in la is
fake it's like nah i mean you stay north
of the 10 freeway like you know you
are
on
no disrespect on fairfax all day on
melrose all day and you know it's kind
of like oh go where the culture is you
know go go where you could get some good
food at go you know
to haroon right in la murray park you
know where where where where you get a
sense of like real community you know so
i feel i i personally feel like that's
the biggest misconception of l.a and a
lot of times
honestly
it'd be
like people that will come here and
adapt to a mentality that they feel like
they have to have to live in l.a
and a lot of people you know for the
most part you know they they meet people
like that and they feel like everybody
in l.a is like that and that's not well
and most of the time because like
there's been a few people that have gone
la viral for talking [ __ ] about l.a
right
r b singers we'll get into the who's in
the weeds of it but
but it's like people who aren't even
from here exactly and it's like
obviously you're probably mostly
interacting with people who aren't from
here as well
and or who are very much like involved
in the entertainment industry and
unfortunately exactly in the
entertainment industry it just is what
it is most people are full of [ __ ]
that everywhere and no matter what
you're a part of yeah but like i do feel
like particularly like i understand how
someone could be scorned by like their
experience in the music industry but
like
just because someone lives here like you
know they're right it's not the same
thing correct and it's like if you're
not from here shut the [ __ ] up
that's it like you're you're here you're
here you know you're taking the good
right you love the like there's a reason
why you're here right exactly because
you kind of have to be here for your
career correct so if you could get all
that positive out of los angeles
but didn't want to go on twitter and
[ __ ] on like
[ __ ] homeless people or the whole you
know all these little things like right
right at least beautiful though man like
there's so many different like nuances
and like
la is such a dynamic city it's like
really whatever you're looking for you
can get here yeah exactly and really if
you just if you want to drive within
like three hours of la it's like really
limitless it's like you could go to the
[ __ ] desert and trip on shrooms at
joshua tree
you can go to irvine and exactly
it's it's just so many different layers
to the city you know like how you said
you want to go to
joshua tree palm springs coachella it's
not too far from that it's like its own
little country loki southern california
it's wild correct um
you have a record the one record that i
heard from you that really kind of like
grabbed me was the heaven and hennessy
record which i felt like was like a
super dope vulnerable record um
is it your biggest record on spotify i
want to say so yeah um
that record uh
we don't get a lot of like
artists really kind of channeling what
it like what those emotions are on songs
where you really feel them i guess like
where were you what place were you at in
life when you when you wrote that and
recorded it a frustrated place
trying to figure life out where i'm
going where i'm heading where i was you
know and just being stuck in between
like a rock and a hard place not only
in
like my community but like
in my career right you know like
when am i gonna get this
like everything that i've been like
being i feel like i've been working
towards and it's just like damn when am
i gonna get this break like this big
break that us this artist always
imagined that we're gonna have and this
is that in the third and it was just
kind of like
for me
i'm like okay i need to bear it all and
i need to explain where i'm at and how i
feel because i know there are other
people out there
whether you're whatever it is or
whatever industry that you work in you
know that feel like how i feel
you know so it was just really just
getting that on record you know and um
um
man
everybody tells me all the time like man
having a hennessy that's one of my
favorite records i just did a pop-up and
somebody hit me they were like yo
can you guys play heaven and hennessy
i'm pulling up make sure y'all play
heavy hennessy that's one of my favorite
records so when did things kind of start
to
change for you in terms of like momentum
or like like was it an opportunity was
it a certain moment where like things
started to kind of like some of those
frustrations were like alleviated a
little bit um i want to say um
with the release of save yourself like
with the release of save yourself um
uh
because you had all them playlists
unlocked yeah yeah yeah for artists with
your following yeah i was like yo they
really gotta [ __ ] with him because we
don't see this a lot yeah yeah nah it
was honestly just people just
gravitating towards the music and just
like doing things and um thinking
outside the box during the pandemic
because we couldn't do shows so you know
me myself and my team
my manager drew we were just like kind
of just brainstorming like how can we
further um
you know our agenda being locked inside
the house so we came up with the idea of
like putting together like a live series
session those were dope or you'd be like
in the backyard yeah yeah yeah and then
you perform like
super dope literally my camera dude no
excuse mentality exactly yeah we're like
okay all right what can we do and we
just came up with that and my camera
dude he did the whole thing we did it in
his backyard you know wow i got a couch
i think that was actually my couch from
my house put in the backyard called up
some of the homies you know laid a janky
little uh
uh rug on the floor no
that [ __ ] stood out to me because i was
like man like uh you and the the dude
from the baylor russell
yeah i just love what y'all were doing
with like the online content because i
feel like we always think like you know
one of the biggest excuses artists will
have is like i ain't got money for a
music video or
you know i don't got a budget to do this
this and it's like yo really
and i you say use the camera guy but
like low-key you really if you have a
[ __ ] iphone and a real creative
thought process like you can create some
fire [ __ ]
listen
it's so many i i look at how we used to
live life before technology really
started booming and i'm like man we're
really privileged
you can do whatever you want if you
don't know how to do something
everything is googleable and you can
just hit up youtube learn how to play
the piano learn how to learn how to do
whatever so it's just no it is wild that
is true yeah yeah yeah youtube is
low-key made like
cookbooks and like how-to books like
extinct i'm telling you my wife was like
telling me she's like i think i want to
make a cookbook and i'm like why [ __ ]
start a youtube channel yeah i'm telling
you nobody's buying any [ __ ]
cookbooks anymore yeah i'm so even like
they're they got these instagram chefs
now where it's like they show you how to
cook in like 30 seconds i just was on a
dude's page today
who who went to mcdonald's and he bought
a filet-o-fish
and he took it home and he made his own
version of it oh my gosh and it looks so
fire i'm telling you and i was like damn
i like watched like four videos yeah no
it's wild yeah and he probably saved
like even think about printing
directions
what you know like back then it's like
yo you had to print out what was that
map to map quest even before that like
when i was a little kid and my [ __ ]
dad used to buy the map book out of the
[ __ ] liquor store
that [ __ ] is like i can't even imagine
existing in the world without gps that
is yeah that's crazy because you really
like now you really don't need to learn
anything
you just need to get in your car and
just look like go right right to where
before you really had to like
you driving looking down at what turns
you trying to make and like well you
gotta like really like okay like i gotta
remember that this is here yeah
yeah not anymore yep not anymore so i
was just like you know really a no
excuse attitude and facts you know just
honestly just diy and just getting to it
you know you feel like the type of
artist that top dog would try to sign
yeah any discussions happen i mean
obviously you got the record with reason
the video reason i've gotten that a lot
man and i really i i respect like
honestly like when i really um
sat down and like was like yo i want to
do this music thing and i just seen like
top dog and him come up in the city the
way that they did it was very inspiring
for me you know and
um kendrick is my favorite artist you
know so to see like in the beginning of
his career like the level of honesty you
know in the transparency sex you know
that was a like he used to really
transcend you know
show me a lot like this this is before
you're real with the world you got to be
real with yourself you know so
with the whole name change and
everything like that like how he did i i
saw that and it was it inspired me so
yeah i
[ __ ] with those guys a lot yeah yeah
i mean but you also just build your own
td exactly you know what i'm saying i
think for me it's just you know just
seeing and taking a lot of um
of what uh i would like to call like the
la renaissance guys like you know tde
and guys like dom kennedy shout out to
dom you know what i'm saying you and i
thirst you know
oh yeah yeah active hack div you know
just seeing how they were such a great
area yeah yeah i was one of the i was
talking to somebody about that the other
day i said somebody needs to um
somebody needs to make a documentary
about that area
yeah this is the blog broadcast
of l.a rap it was a show every week you
know and i was going to all of you
forgot about you and i yeah yeah yeah
you and i you had casey veggies sean
christie yeah sean christopher was so
cold yeah man yeah he was working with
wale for a little bit yeah yeah yeah i
believe so i have a sean christopher he
had a record uh i think he was signed to
timberland too i think i think he was
yeah i think john christopher was cold i
think he was yeah but just like being in
la at that time that was like
el prez shout out to prayer that's
that's that's my dog yeah like seeing
exactly like you know prayers and like
seeing those guys like really do it how
they do it did it at that time and just
you know they would throw their own
shows and like and it was
they did it together too like it was a
show every week you know what i'm saying
and you will see familiar names on the
right on the bill you know and just
seeing how they were doing it you know
that that inspired me i was able to like
participate in that stuff definitely i
was i was i was and just like just go to
shows cause before then i was so trapped
in like you know what i'm saying just
going to work every day and like you
know i think my first taste of
um
of uh
life outside of my neighborhood was you
know when i started
uh working at the grove and you know
just it's like i think for me everything
expanded for me at that time even like
my taste in music and stuff like that
and i've heard something crazy i've
lived here six years i've never been to
the beverly center or the grove really
never
i don't know why i just never i have no
idea that's crazy those are two places
like i've driven by both many times and
i've always been like
how have i ever been inside of there
that's crazy that's actually pretty
crazy it is kind of crazy that's pretty
crazy you've never been there for
anything like for nothing that's wow for
literally nothing that's my like go-to
like for christmas shopping like yeah i
don't know i think it's because i've
lived in the valley the whole time so
like
i don't know yeah i just never have gone
to like like i've been up i've been over
there a lot but i just never like just
yeah have happened to go i've been in to
slaughter and swap me like seven times
i've been and no you've never been to
the grove
that's actually pretty crazy it's crazy
yeah it's like crazy i hear you know i
gotta check out the grove yeah yeah yeah
i heard that they put like um
there's like because of the smash and
grab [ __ ] they had to put a bunch of
like wild ass like fences around the
grove or some [ __ ] uh man funny enough i
haven't been to the grove in a minute
it's been a minute yeah it's been a
while since i've been to the grove but i
could probably imagine after everything
[ __ ] is turned up right now yeah yeah
yeah definitely a hundred percent a
hundred percent it's pretty crazy yeah
it's pretty crazy so
you know before that era we were talking
about there was like
i grew up
so i'm three years older than you but my
best friend's brother is in a rap group
called dilated peoples
a word which is uh
probably the most un like legendary
[ __ ] underground boom bap rap group
in l.a history it's either them or
jurassic five
living legends shot at living life um so
when i was like 12 and 13
i'd come to la from arizona
uh and hang out with like
those guys the alcoholics
[ __ ] exhibit wow uh and like i went
to both of their album release parties
out here wow
the pl uh was the platform and it was
uh expansion team
but it was kind of crazy because like i
would be at fat beats i don't know if
you ever went to fat beats what the
um was it on melrose i don't [ __ ]
know man i just know it was upstairs it
was on melrose so like yeah i was at fat
beats like when i was like 13 and like
it was just such such an ill vibe like
because that was to me like peak
underground la [ __ ] cuz that was like
those guys got like real major deals out
of that [ __ ] yeah that's crazy fat beats
bro so when i so that so that's another
thing when i was working at the grove
it you know that's where i discovered
like like melrose and all of that stuff
you know i was like what 17 18 years old
just walking on melrose
i come by fat beats you know i come
across fat beats and i'm like yo what's
this you know and a whole bunch of like
vinyls and yeah records and like fat
beats survive yeah that's crazy and then
they they close down after that but
around that time i was like you know
like yo
let me let me let me print up a few of
my like songs on a cd
and take it to flat beats and see if
it's cool if they'll just like have them
at the front and like if somebody
purchases whatever they purchase i could
give away my cd with that you know
fat beats back low key people like you
know vinyl sells more than like like
vinyl really be selling now i think fat
beads did open back up i think they're
in downtown if i'm not mistaken i know
that i know they're a record label now
yeah yeah yeah yep i know they put out
like indie rap [ __ ] i don't know yeah
but yeah
a record store yeah would be crazy yeah
fat beats legendary fat beats was a vibe
that's crazy hey we got to stop the
interview real quick man shout out to
our sponsors at my bookie now if you're
into sports like me you like to win
money what are we doing go to my bookie
right now man let's get in on some of
this action
my bookie
go sign up get the double deposit bonus
that's what this means when you sign up
in my bookie right now
all right whatever money you would
deposit they're gonna match it they're
gonna double it for you up to a thousand
dollars but you gotta use the keyword
the promo code
bootleg that's right use that promo code
bootleg when you sign up at my bookie
they're gonna double your deposit listen
march madness is coming up
my favorite time of the year to gamble
is march madness it is so much fun you
don't got to know a [ __ ] thing about
college basketball it is just [ __ ]
turnt up i love to go to
listen march madness that's really all
you need to know get your account before
then thank me later also nba action is
finally back throw down some futures who
do you think is going to win the mvp
joel embiid jokic devin booker little
dark horse you know i'm saying shout out
to the suns uh you got to go to my
bookie though sign up get down right now
all right get double your money double
your deposit you put in a thousand
they're gonna match that give you a
whole another thousand to gamble with
mybookie.ag
use the promo code bootleg double your
deposit um you just put out a new record
in video where
there had to have been nothing in the
coffee cup right there was
might have been a little something
because i'm like brothers your white tea
your white tea would not have stayed
white
might have been a little something there
was actual coffee in there it's it's all
it's all in the driving you know the
driver was going he wasn't he wasn't
going like you know
like trans he wasn't on his transporter
vibes like where he was that like a
sketchy video to try to shoot just in
terms of like hanging out the top of a
car nah man it was honestly it was just
like yo we just pop out and just you
know get what we need go back down get
my presidential you know wave to the
people say hi people are looking at you
crazy like they were who the [ __ ] is
this
they really were they were they really
were and um my camera guy he was like
he was just you know he popped out too
and said so they're like yo what what
the [ __ ] is going on like what are you
guys shooting but you know it was cool i
felt very comfortable i was in my
neighborhood and you know i i came up
with the idea um of just like you know i
thought i always thought it would be
cool to like
do some [ __ ] like that like i that came
out dope yeah
it was like you know
we go on king boulevard for like an hour
shoot that is that um like what is your
let's kind of like like obviously this
is that just a single or is that going
to be connected to a new body of work or
what's what's next for you it's a single
um it's a single that that is connected
to to a body of work that you know
that's being put together right now i
should be out very soon so yeah you know
but i think for me it's just just kind
of hitting people with like music like
you know what i'm saying yeah you can't
let people unfortunately man unless you
unless you're kendrick or you're like
the weeknd or
you can't really like just sit on your
hands for three years yeah nah man look
roddy rich couldn't even do it yeah
exactly yeah that's my dog but like he i
feel like he waited too long
yeah you know what i mean like did you
like that project
his new album yeah i wasn't fond of it
were i didn't think it was as bad as
everyone said it was but i also didn't
think it was good and i'm a big fan of
him and and his whole discography and
uh
i just think sometimes when you sit on
[ __ ] too long you start psyching
yourself out about it
because i had heard stuff on that was
supposed to be on a version of his
second album
that wasn't on the album
and at least from what i've heard most
of his album that we
got was
fairly recently recorded
so i think artists make a mistake a lot
of times and i don't know i'm not
speaking on him in particular but i just
i do i do know that like
whenever you're sitting on a song for
too long it becomes old to you even if
no one's heard it that's true and then
you'll start to think that like the new
[ __ ] you did is better than the [ __ ]
that you knew that you know was hard and
it's like it's just like
especially now man i think people
overthink their music they're like like
yo just like what you like just put some
[ __ ] out like put it out just cut it out
let's put it out the longer you said it
just kind of like yeah and then like
people most music
that like like when i'm like like a lot
of artists that i know
i hear songs and i'm i'll talk to them
three or four years later but yeah
whatever happened to that [ __ ] song
right like you know we just did it man
it just got old they got tired yeah i'm
like that [ __ ] was hard yeah yeah yeah
and i'm not a fan of like announcing
like oh yeah new music coming soon and
then having people wait like two
years or like right now for me if i'm
like yo new music is coming soon it's
probably coming in like roddy's got to
drop asap now like he's really got to
like
yeah 90 days in the next 90 days we
better get some vermont yeah
i like him i like i really like him in
uh mustards um
oh yeah they don't miss yeah they fall
in late at night high fashion come on
yeah yeah what i actually heard was a
lot of the um
original project was supposed to be more
like late at night a word so i don't
know what happened word i think i think
when you're someone like ronnie rich
you're like a pop star you're like a
superstar yeah yeah and i think that
like this project it felt to me like he
was trying to compete with like the
little babies and dirks of the world as
opposed to like the post malones of the
world if that makes sense right all
right i mean i'm like right here stadium
artist bro like right
right and it's all you know so it's all
a learning experience even for him for
sure you know for sure and he's a great
dude and he's and he's
so talented he's gonna be fine yeah but
i can only imagine like
mentally that's just gotta take a toll
on you people talking [ __ ] about your
art so much yeah for sure i mean i was
just talking to somebody the other day
it's just kind of like you know as an
artist you know there's a level of
bravery that goes into being an artist
because you work on something so hard
that you think every every song that you
are preparing to put out you feel like
okay it's on the album for a reason you
must really [ __ ] with it right and then
you know you put it out in hopes that
people like it you know you put your
work out
you know
just open to everybody everyone's
critiquing everyone is a critic now yeah
and everybody is a twitter anr everyone
has access to tell you how they feel
about your [ __ ] come on back in the day
they have to see what the mall or
something yeah exactly exactly they
exactly they would have to you know
write fan mail or something like that
you know so
yeah nah i definitely um i yeah i think
he i think he'll be good uh
what about on this new project have you
gotten do you have any features locked
in um yeah yes yeah we working on it
we're working on it we're working on it
we're working on it
we working on it i take a guess
la
artists yeah obviously yeah yeah
hmm
buddy
can't confirm nor deny there it is
[Music]
[Laughter]
you should [ __ ] with ray vaughn too i
want to hear you in ravel oh i mean i
[ __ ] with ray vaughn i actually saw him
um
i saw him
yeah he man he's super cold he's super
called i saw him at uh
um where was it oh dee smokes um show at
the roxy in which i performed and he was
he was there and i saw him he was just
by himself
yeah that's how he rolls yeah very
adorable dude
i love it i love it bro i love it you
know i'm saying he's chill he's super
humble and he's dope he's he's really
dove i think tde definitely has
gold on her hands oh with him yeah i
think he's like to me like when i think
of tde and like obviously kendrick's uh
on his last project so
uh i think rayvon is the one guy that
they have
that's like young that can be like
a supe like a star right you got star
quality so shout out to yeah for sure
for sure um what about like just in
general like how do you spend your free
time man when you're not recording when
you're not making content what are you
doing man i'm at the beach bro i'm
telling you that's what i'm like bro la
is just like you know so you love the
beach bro i love the beach i love going
to malibu i love just like being out
there and just like you know just
catching a vibe just like you know just
most people don't hang out at the beach
from l.a they don't they don't it's kind
of crazy they don't but i'm like you can
take advantage of this
i'm like you know how many people that
live
in phoenix that wish they all come here
to [ __ ] sit at the beach you know
what i'm saying yeah it's crazy most
people who live here don't go to the
[ __ ] beach it's not a thing right i
think it's because it's a drive
for the most part
unless you live over there but like the
most part but it's a it's a it's a drive
it is but it's it's just like so
relaxing and sometimes like even when
you're out that way it doesn't even feel
like you're in l.a anymore for sure
that's facts so it's just kind of like
you know your favorite beach is malibu
my favorite beach i have a few i like el
matador which is in malibu right um you
know and yeah malibu feels like you're
somewhere else it feels like you're
somewhere else yeah it really feels like
you're like
like you're in a different state or
something i'm telling you it's kind of
wow i i encourage everybody like you
know just take advantage of if you live
in l.a and you paying for
high-ass rent you got to take advantage
you got to take advantage of all the
amenities that's crazy come on
so i'm just like yo dude i just went to
palm springs for the first time this
past weekend with my wife i've driven
through that [ __ ] like 150 times going
going to phoenix but um
like i actually like went to palm
springs
had lunch and [ __ ] and then we
went to joshua tree and spent the night
in h rooms in the desert it was amazing
but
it's like i was just telling my wife the
same [ __ ] i'm like man this [ __ ] is kind
of crazy like
we don't ever come over here it's two
hours away what the [ __ ] are we doing
like all right this [ __ ] is so like
right it's like a whole nother
vibe right right right man you'll be
taking trips kevin i saw you a few days
ago man i don't know where i was in palm
springs on a horse oh word
[Music]
yeah my wife wanted to ride a horse for
her birthday so word i was fired was
that your like first time like you're
writing or worse
maybe
i might have did when i was a kid but
that's just not comfortable man i
i just oh no i'm you rode a horse no
yeah it's not comfortable cause like we
we it was like a two-hour uh excursion
like in the like [ __ ] hills of palm
springs and that [ __ ] was not
comfortable my legs were sore
the horse kept [ __ ] like yeah
[Music]
we watched a show called yellowstone um
and that's what it's a cowboy show and
that [ __ ] that's what inspired that or
yeah word yeah like let's go ride some
[ __ ] horses by the way yellowstone is
gas everyone should go watch it or kevin
costner's in it okay
who
grew up with compton
that tripped me out when i saw and found
that out kevin costner's from compton
california
[Music]
uh really mean mean it subscribe like
leave a comment even if you're one of
those [ __ ] who leaves a comment yo
why you always interrupting the guest
because it's my [ __ ] podcast i don't
know i like to talk too
anyway hey shout out to odd socks man
they've been our sponsor from day one we
go hard for odd socks always man
literally go hard for my wife and i go
hard for odd socks
in different and same kinds of ways you
know what i'm saying sometimes i go hard
in odd socks
they do make boxers
you feel me
anyway um listen they got the ill
licenses they got the breaking bad they
got the wwe they got mountain dew they
got [ __ ] swedish fish [ __ ]
kool-aid
uh
pez you know
cheech and chong what are you into the
odd socks basics are the boys though
that's my favorite you know you get
yourself a nice pair of just basics
they're comfy it's like walking on
clouds all right so you can save 20 off
if you go to oddssoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev that's
one word bootleg kev
all together
at checkout 20 off oddssocksofficial.com
go show some love and let's get back to
the interview
is it like for you being like an artist
who obviously
um
you're very much yourself you're very
much you know high on artistic integrity
is it like kind of hard to be that
artist in 2022
like do you ever get
you know there's so many shortcuts to
like i guess clout or
going viral or just [ __ ] like that like
like like is it is it hard to stay
focused on like your mission and making
sure you don't kind of allow outside
[ __ ] to kind of interfere on
with the way you move i guess in this
industry um
for me no
because i know i'm locked into a i'm
locked in i'm locked in purpose
you know just like my vision and my goal
like what i you know when it's all said
done
you know the work that i leave behind or
like my kids are going to listen to am i
going to be proud of that right you know
so for me it's just like just just
seeing and knowing that that's what
keeps me
tunnel vision like you know i don't let
the trends of whatever is going on come
in you know dilute whatever it is that
i'm doing you know because a lot of
stuff that's happening now you know what
i'm saying a lot of it is fly by night
[ __ ] 100 man it's here today is going
tomorrow right a lot of the stuff that
was around three or four years ago two
years ago two years ago you know so no i
would yeah no i think like uh when we
think of like who's been at the top of
the rap game for the last decade it's
three guys it's kendrick cullen drake
and like they're all incredibly just
next level amazing at just rapping right
exactly and that should be that's proof
like that's like like clear they're like
never it's like they're like i'm the
present like it's like they're
irrelevant no matter what same thing
like i mean you could even go back
further and say jay-z you know like
right jay if jay puts the album out
tomorrow he's
it's
no one's gonna be like what the [ __ ] is
this out of here out of here out of it
to the point where it's just kind of
like you know dave gaine guys like cole
and you know and they've kind of like
dictated the market to where it's just
like okay
i could just come out and just put out
an album without a single or anything
and you know my fans are gonna love it
and eat it up and you know they're gonna
appreciate it you know and
you know
it it's yeah that's that's what it is
but yeah i think those three are like
clear-cut proof for sure
you uh did some stuff with the rams i
saw yeah yeah now are you like a og rams
fan or
honestly i for me
i'm just happy we got a team okay i'm
one of those i'm not
were you a football fan prior to the
rams coming back to la i don't really i
see i watch football every now and then
okay i'm not like i'm more basketball
okay okay that's you know yeah that's
yeah shout out to the lakers man a lot
of rings a lot of rings i will say that
a lot of rings but it's rough right now
we got to get it together we got to get
it together we got to get it together
y'all you know you guys unfortunately
unfortunately put us put us out of our
misery very early in the playoffs yeah
you know what nothing was the same
after lebron taunted jay crowder on this
when it was him and drummond and
drummond was taunting
jay crowder right yeah yeah nothing's
been the same since then but nothing
made me happier than seeing you know
giannis like kind of like he killed it
no he killed it he killed us he did and
very
epic way yeah yeah but no i think i
think um
i don't know we just got to get it
together i feel like
you know two teams that i feel like if
we don't get it together and who who
will be a problem for us is phoenix and
golden state i think though i think
those are the two teams in the west that
like
also low-key
if paul george and kawhi leonard come
back
somehow in the last couple of weeks of
the season where they can sneak into the
play-in and they come back in the
playoffs and i hate the clippers
i hate kawhi leonard but they just got
[ __ ] robert covington
they just got
norman powell from the clippers
bro they could start four or five guys
that can defend anyone that's true yeah
but [ __ ] the clippers yeah so why do you
hate kawhi he'd be so quiet man kawhi is
a [ __ ]
i didn't like what he did to lebron to
be honest i thought he hold out he kind
of hold lebron and held out on him and
then
i'm a lebron fan oh when he came to l.a
yeah so like i'm a die-hard lebron fan
so like i've
the sons have been so i mean i'm a
die-hard sons fan but
i've always been like okay lebron always
played in the east and the sun sucked so
i was always just rooting for lebron or
the sons yeah so fair enough when he
came to la i had a real serious
uh conflict inside because i hate the
lakers but
i just love lebron so
i really felt like kawhi ho lebron low
key damn i mean
and then and then
they had to just gr get all the scraps
off the [ __ ] off they literally
because all the free agents signed that
year oh yeah we were we were so they
were just grabbing whoever avery [ __ ]
bradley who i mean obviously they got a
ring so it didn't matter but yeah i i
don't know quiet to me is a very
i just don't like the way he'd be moving
he's sitting up in the [ __ ] owner's
box
he's so low-key bro it's the playoffs
why are you sitting up to go sit with
your [ __ ] teammates
that's hilarious
i'd like him on my team he so do you
feel like he's top 75 of all time or
uh
probably but
[ __ ] him i don't know man i mean the
fact that he
he came
i thought that was some of the most
legendary [ __ ] to come
to toronto toronto get a ring year one
all is forgiving no i don't disagree i
mean he's amazing if you look at his
career stats though they're extremely
low compared to everyone else because of
the amount of games he hasn't played a
lot of games because he's always injured
he does it a lot i think kyrie irving
should have been
kyrie and dwight should have been in the
top 75. i could definitely agree with
that i i had this argument with a friend
as far as like dwight goes i do feel
like he's had he would he ran what do
you like he went to the finals uh he was
like [ __ ] i don't know how many
defensive players of the year he was the
best center in the league for at least
10 years that's what i was i i think the
white house
people for sure forget like how good he
was because of like
you know whoever he you know he kind of
turned into a goof and a bad teammate
later on but like dude dwight howard was
that [ __ ] yeah nah dwight is
definitely he's hall of fame for sure i
would put kyrie in over dame lillard to
be honest hmm what does t-max fit in all
of that because he got left out i think
i think t-mac just didn't have enough
years like
i think tmac could have been like as
like that
all-time great but i just feel like
injuries just kind of [ __ ] them up you
know
it did like i don't know yeah
i don't know i think
i think kyrie irving
and i haven't liked kyrie for some time
just like how he moves and [ __ ] and i
actually
uh respect the way he's handling the
vaccine thing
um but uh i think he's probably the most
skilled player ever yeah that
motherfucker's like art like if you
watch kyrie irving play basketball in
slow motion it is the most beautiful bat
it's like ballet yeah not literally like
just like
it's like he has like an invisible
string it's like the head like the ball
is his hand yeah and i literally it's
like literally literally and he's just
like dribbling it's like you know and i
think he's
to me
at the rim i think he's
one of the best finishers out there and
he won a [ __ ] ring with cleveland and
he won that ring he stunned steph curry
and hit that shot like you got him you
saw it you bay area [ __ ]
[Laughter]
they got that switch and he said no i
want him he he stepped up you wanted
your god and he and steph cruz oh i got
this he didn't have it did he he stepped
up man he was picking on steph the whole
series because you're [ __ ] sorry i'm
talking to my producer who's swinging on
steph curry's nuts
every
it's steph curtis he's having one of the
best
oh who gives a [ __ ]
he's the best basketball player ever
shut the [ __ ] up
the best basketball player ever
relax bro he's got like four years left
before like he's just a sixth band
somewhere chill out
do you think he's winning mvp this
season [ __ ] no it's gonna be yokitra
embiid cease wow no it's gonna be
yolkajar embiid and beat it's like you
think so are you serious i mean i mean
i'm a gambling man so i look at the odds
it's going to be yokatra embiid strong
embiid is
ballin
steph is having a crazy
score 50 points in like 25 minutes like
two weeks ago like so how do you like
harden over there
i don't know i'm not sure hardin is
i don't know what to think of james
anymore to be honest nice guy i'm cool
with him like i just don't know of like
you know i think he wants the executive
produce rap albums you know if i'm being
honest
[Music]
i'm not sure he like wants to be the mvp
of the nba anymore but he's back with
daryl murray so you know i like him beat
a lot uh so i hope that they i hope it
goes well i really uh
i can't say i don't [ __ ] with katie
because i met him and he was super nice
and i've been to his house and yeah
i think brooklyn is brooklyn katie katie
did some whole ass [ __ ] when he went to
golden state damn
i mean i yeah i wasn't [ __ ] with that
i i definitely wasn't but then i i met
him and he was like the nicest guy yeah
so i was like uh and i talked to him for
like 30 minutes i was like god damn it i
hope he doesn't check my twitter for
like four years
top three greatest scorers of all time
to me kd for sure he's in there
definitely pure score like just
hot take you ready for the hot take
we'll start katie over kobe
uh
i don't uh when it's all said and done
see you didn't i don't know if i could
agree with that but you're but you know
what i appreciate the fact that you did
not shoot it down yeah because you're an
actual basketball fan right
kobe's top 10 all time i love kobe but i
think when it's all said and done katie
is going to be like he's going to be
knocking on that like larry bird
like
magic johnson oh we talking all like all
around or are we just like when we talk
about just just career-wise best no no
no not scoring okay
i think the best scorer is low-key james
harden in the nba right now i just think
in the last like 20 years who's been a
better scorer like harden literally the
whole entire thing was iso
the whole offense was just iso
james was fired i like changed the nba i
like james they had to fix the free
throw rule because of him
and and and they had to change they
should have won two mvps they had to
change the pump fake
jump into the person that's scoring you
might not like it he changed the nba
list that's that's he did i mean i i i
personally think that
i think steph
revolution no steph changed like the way
kids wanna through three point [ __ ] is
that's ridiculous but there's like ev
every every now and then you have just
like you know like trey young came out
of like steph curry's nuts like without
steph curry that trey young wouldn't be
in the nba definitely i think so because
he wouldn't have played the way he
played i think like between like like
yeah every now and then you just have
those players that they come and they
just revolutionize the game no steps
i'll give steph that all day as much as
i think he's a little [ __ ] i'll give him
that he's changed the nba forever
and he's amazing he is very good man
don't let don't let golden state play
phoenix oh we're smoking them man i'm
putting all my money on the signs oh man
that's gonna be what are you talking
about
i gotta see this
i wanna see this he don't even want that
to happen because he knows when the
sun's wind he's not built for this for
this smoke man i just hope we win i hope
we just get it together figure it out i
gotta get into playing yeah i know man
hey i think the lakers have to somehow
convince what russell westbrook to be a
sixth man if they can if kendrick
nothing's not happening if kendrick nunn
comes back and starts a point guard
and you got the little white rookie
hidden threes what's his [ __ ] name
austin reeves that was
uh
best best [ __ ] nickname since
kirilenko ak-4747 exactly he just stands
in the corner hit threes
let lebron facilitate let a dude do his
thing and then just bring in the second
union and have russ
hold it down man good luck that's the
problem it's like no because imagine
dude the lakers would actually be good
if they could convince russell westbrook
to be a sixth man be a sixth man what
you bringing russ off the bench against
the second union i mean i could i i can
see it
i don't think
russell can say oh no
and i might
he should start on other teams yeah but
not on the lakers it just doesn't make
sense obviously it's a [ __ ] mess man
i thought it was gonna be like one of
those situations where you know i feel
like everybody that plays with lebron um
uh
i feel like lebron does make
players better you would hope that he
would make russell kind of kick back a
little kick back a little yeah that that
was my hope at the end of those games
russell westbrook got the ball at so you
know the game's over like yeah well damn
man i thought honestly
we we were looking better with
malone peyton kobe and shaq than we
are now currently i mean that team went
to the finals they did but you watched
the pistons exactly but even then but
you went to the finals we went we went
to the finals right and you know even
then everybody was like you know it was
kind of like oh yeah that was a terrible
season for us
but
you know seeing the season that we have
now might we'll see what happens i think
i think i think if the lakers make it
into the playoffs nobody wants to see
them in the first round because you
still got to play a d and lebron james
man you got 80 guys and they show the
sons and you saw him in the first round
last year and beat him and bounced the
ass anyway
we'd like to see him that's fair two
years in a row bring it here baby bring
it that's fair that's fair 80 got to
stay healthy yes
he's the glass man man
um so when when are we going to get this
project like uh first of all how how
close are you from being finished with
your new album oh it's it's it's the
project yeah okay so that so when is it
gonna come out soon i can't say when
soon you got big announcements coming uh
i might yeah you may or may not have
some big announcements i may not you
know shooting visuals and stuff like
that where uh can people just support
what you got going on i'm sure you got
merch you got yes sir
nana is king on instagram nana is king
underscore why nana uh that's actually
my real name that's your real name
that's my real name
from ghana um
i was always self-conscious you know in
in la you know my wife's mexican and you
know
nana's granny yeah like grandma you know
what i'm saying but yeah and like
so where my parents are from um yeah it
means king that's why it's not enough
have you been back i have been i have
been in uh when i was uh like
14. i just beautiful it's super
beautiful yeah that's why everybody goes
there and every day everyone's going on
vacation out there now yeah it's good
it's it's beautiful it's one of the most
beautiful places you'll ever go to slept
on two extremely slept on yeah extremely
small prices bleep all this out so like
it we don't let the secret out yeah i
know i know i mean you know it turns
into tulum
[Music]
tulum is the secret's out yeah but the
thing is you know what i'm saying a lot
of people can't deal with the flight you
know what i'm saying so yeah that's a
serious flight going into looming [ __ ]
going to africa oh you're just like 20
hours going to paris like i went to
paris once i said this [ __ ] this is
terrible i don't know if i ever go back
to europe after this [ __ ]
[ __ ] flight is the worst anyway um go
support and um go run up the new video
stream the new song yes sir better back
out now on all streaming platforms
check out the album check out yep save
yourself been out and yeah man thank you
for having me oh good man appreciate it
boom